Good morning John.
So for the first time in a long time, I don't
have anything like super pressing to make
a video about today.
I mean, I got ideas, got plenty of ideas,
but instead of doing one of those things,
I decided to turn this video over to the Nerdfighters
of Facebook and Twitter and Tumblr and Reddit
to decide for me what I would do in this video.
"Pretend to be a crab!"
Oookay.
Rawwwawraaawaahh.
"Spiderman."
Donald Glover.
All the way.
"Show us Lemon and her derpiness!"
"Talk about throwing paper balls near cats
and their subsequent reactions."
Felis catus, the domesticated house cat.
Interests include meat pâté, warm things
and strings.
The cat considers the paper ball to be a little
bit like a mice.
It moves and skitters and makes noises like
a mice, but is not juicy like a mice.
"Juggling!"
"Nerdy Valentines Day jokes!"
I could never break up with my goalie girlfriend;
she's a keeper.
I have a friend who married a librarian.
Instead of giving him a ring at the wedding
ceremony, she just stamped him: "Not for circulation".
Yeah, nup, movin' on!
"Can you tell us anything about your book?"
Yeah, I'm thinking about writing a fiction-y
thing.
Right now it's about a girl, uh, and a robot
and what it means to be human.
"Please play Minecraft!"
This is the Nerdcrafteria Minecraft server
which is always beautiful, but is right now
decorated for Valentines Day.
Isn't it adorable?
"Don a speedo, cover self in peanut butter/bacon
mixture, talk about Gundam."
No!
No.
"TV recommendations please!"
Agent Carter, Agent Carter, Agent Carter,
Agent Carter, Agent Carter.
Andrew asks: "What are some of your favourite
things that likely very few people have heard
of?"
The animated series Kodocha, Locke and Key
comics, Paolo Bacigalupi, the creations of
Neil Cicierega, the board game Robot Ricochet
and let's go with TheThirdPew.
"Show us your lunch!"
Five Guys!
They have free peanuts, but I have to have
my hamburgers on hot dog buns because I can't
eat sesame seeds.
"Make video explaining the Keystone XL Pipeline."
Okay, uh, the Keystone XL is an extension
of the current Keystone Pipeline.
It would go all the way from Alberta to Louisiana,
which is a long way.
The idea being we could get all the oil from
the Tar Sands down to the ports there where
we could ship it all over the world.
I think this is a bad idea; the biggest reason
is that the Tar Sands are the second biggest
sink of carbon in the world.
And they're a super inefficient source of
oil.
It takes a lot of energy, and thus produces
a lot of carbon dioxide, just to turn it into
a usable product.
So you're creating a ton of carbon dioxide
even before you burn the oil.
Tar Sands are what we call unconventional
oil, and ideally, we will leave all of the
unconventional oil in the ground.
'Cause once we start burning the unconventional
oil, there is so much of it, there's just
so much and it, that's just game over for
climate change.
"Try spinning a staff/baton/sword/stick."
"Draw my life!"
Okay, we've not done that yet.
I'm Hank Green.
I live in Montana, where I take up a trivial
amount of space.
Montana, on the other hand, is a fairly small
percentage of the Earth.
The Earth, meanwhile, is a truly minuscule
amount of space in the solar system which
is likewise basically insignificant compared
to the size of our galaxy which, once again,
is completely trivial compared to the size
of the known universe.
My life will take place during an amount of
time, that is, on a universal scale, not just
insignificant, but unnoticeable.
My life.
I drew it.
"Make a cover song or a parody!"
[singing a la "Blank Space"] 'Cause it's all
up on my head part, well maybe just the front.
Being the owner of it ain't hard, can't think
of what I'd rather want.
I've been told it's pretty awesome, better
than a bottle of champagne.
I got a Hank face baby, and I'll write your
name.
On my face.
I won't actually do that though.
Okay, I think that's good; it's probably going
to be about 4 minutes.
I'm guessing, but I've been doing this for
a while so I'm probably spot on.
We'll see.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.